in this video i'm going to show you a
quick and easy way to use the new comp
viewer in adobe after effects
[Music]
hey there my name is cameron with motion
science and in today's video i'm going
to show you how to use the new comp
viewer in after effects now if you're
like me you're always looking for ways
to speed up your workflow
and make your life easier and this is
one of those quick tips that's going to
do that so let's take a look okay so
here we are in after effects and we've
got a basic composition here your layout
may look different than mine but
essentially i've got a very simple text
animation with some titles coming up a
long shadow we've got some effects going
on and some pre comps
okay so typically what happens is if you
double click on a precomp and you want
to go into it and you want to work on
this text maybe you want to change the
text
to something different right like let's
call let's just say we're going to
change it to main titles too well you
can't see what's going on in the main
composition without clicking to go back
to the main composition and then seeing
an update here now what if we wanted to
change the position of our type here and
we're just kind of messing around you
know maybe we're taking it up here and
we have to go back and wait for it to
update and see what it looks like no
it's too high so we're going to go back
we're going to drop it back down to here
and look and see hey does it look right
now okay that looks okay to me now
so what's an easy way to see what's
going on in our main composition while
working in a pre comp it's really simple
there's two ways you can do this
you can come over to the window here and
click on title new comp viewer or you
can come down to the composition window
right click and say new
viewer and what that's going to do is
launch a new window okay and you can see
this bottom window has a lock icon right
here and our top window is not locked so
what we can do now is because our bottom
composition is locked to this main
composition we can go to our pre comp
and we can see our precomp here and our
main comp here so now i can move the
titles around and i can see what's going
on in my main comp
and here's another way to look at it
really quickly
if i have this complex animation
happening here
if i jump into like let's say this shape
here which if i jump back out and i turn
this shape off you can see that this is
the back layer it's actually repeating
three different times so it's these
three layers here so i turn them off
they disappear turn them on you can see
them there now if i go into this and i
make adjustments to this precomp it's
hard again to see what's going on in
this main comp
so what i can do is right-click new
viewer so i can go into my pre-comp
and let's say i want to turn this line
off here and i can see immediately
what's happening here or maybe i want to
turn it on and let's say i want to
rotate it so it's something like this
and it's offset you can see what's
happening here maybe i want to turn off
this line maybe i want to turn off this
dot and you just get instant feedback
for what is happening in your main comp
based on what you're doing in the
pre-comp and that's a really simple
quick tip for working within a pre comp
and seeing what's happening
in your main comp i hope that you really
enjoyed this lesson as much as i loved
teaching it so please let me know if you
have any questions in the comments below
i'd love to answer them for you hit that
like button if you enjoyed this video
and please subscribe to this channel it
helps other people find this channel as
well if you're looking to upgrade your
design skill set master the art of style
and execute like a pro i have a course
called stylecraft that you can check out
at motionscience.tv you can also learn
more about this course by clicking the
link in the description below as always
thanks for watching my name is cameron
and this is motion science
you